il y a très longtemps j'ai commis un
péché
j'étais faible vous étiez posséder ce
n'était pas vous je n'ai rien empêché
bienvenus vers 8h ce n'est pas tous les
jours qu'on reçoit la visite d'un saint
je ne suis pas un saint vous aider mon
club depuis 18 ans maintenant les gens
vous aiment nous avons un problème avec
une prisonnière elle a besoin d'un
prêtre
il te veux toi albanais c'est de
posséder
cela ressemble à châtiment du seigneur
nous assisterons manière
lequel
la résurrection
copé chez
sophie c'est ma faute
leurs dessous et les enfants
c'est ma faute
il n'y a pas assez de place dans un même
corps pour dieu et le diable sauver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment vais-je me prendre on ne croyons
pas que dieu est avec toi
mais en croyant fermement que tu es dieu